neuigkeiten zum sicherheitszustand des
unglücksreaktors tschernobyl für 100
jahre sicher 30 jahre ist das reaktor
unglück im kernkraftwerk tschernobyl
schon her
und jetzt gibt es neues jetzt bei klicks
um science-fiction das havarierte
kernkraftwerk abgeschätzt werden vor 30
jahren geschah das unfassbare am 26
april mal seit 86 schmilzt der kern im
block 4 des atomreaktors vom typ reaktor
bolschoi motion oz die kanal nie im
kernkraftwerk tschernobyl der
reaktorkern lag während der katastrophe
frei und brannte in der direkten
umgebung und in weiten teilen europas
wurden die menschen erhöhter
radioaktivität ausgesetzt
in der nachbarstadt pripjat wurde die
bevölkerung 30 stunden lang stark
verstrahlt wie sie schließlich evakuiert
wurde
in westeuropa die man vollkommen
unbedarft mit der situation um so ließen
die veranstalter des riesigen feuerwerk
events rhein in flammen
hunderttausende menschen im radioaktiven
fallout im radioaktivem regen stehen
alle verantwortlichen waren mit dieser
katastrophe vollkommen überfordert es
war ein super gau steht übrigens für
größter anzunehmender unfall laut der
einschätzung von atomphysiker zu beginn
der friedlichen nutzung der atomenergie
sollte sich so an unfalls nur alle 1
million jahre ereignen es gab aber seit
dem beginn der nutzung der atomkraft
mindestens acht kernschmelzen
ein solcher gau findet also statistisch
gesehen alle zehn jahre statt was war
also in tschernobyl passiert einführt
die zulassung des reaktors notwendiger
test sollte mit drei jahren verspätung
endlich durchgeführt werden es sollte
gezeigt werden dass die turbinen bei
einem stromausfall und gleichzeitigem
abschalten des reaktors noch genügend
energie erzeugen um den notbetrieb
aufrecht zu erhalten
in einer solchen situation dauert es
rund 30 bis 60 sekunden bis das
notstromaggregat anläuft in dieser zeit
muss die verbliebene rotationsenergie
der turbinen die steuerungstechnik des
kernkraftwerks mit strom versorgen
sie werden durch den heißen wasserdampf
der durch die hitze der kernreaktion
erzeugt wird
betrieben bei abschaltung des reaktors
und gleichzeitigem stromausfall sind sie
die einzige chance noch ausreichend
energie für den notbetrieb zu erhalten
diese situation musste also hergestellt
werden dafür musste der reaktor
heruntergefahren werden das aber höheren
strombedarf in der ukraine gab musste
der versuch verschoben werden und der
reaktor lief länger in einem niedrigen
leistungsbereich dadurch wurde neutronen
absorbieren des c 935 gebildet ist
beeinflusst die leistung des reaktors
massiv die bedien mannschaft warnte aber
nichts von dieser xenon vergiftung oder
zumindest nichts vom umfang umfang
dieser vergiftung im vorfeld des
versuches gerät der reaktor dann in
immer niedrigere und vor allem nicht
zugelassene leistungsbereiche durch das
xenon war der reaktor zudem nur sehr
schwierig zu steuern
das war fatal in dieser situation wurde
der test begonnen und es wurde eine
kettenreaktion in gang gesetzt die nicht
mehr zu stoppen war
durch diesen super gau wurde ein
riesiges gebiet verseucht und zahlreiche
arbeiter und rettungskräfte kamen dabei
um damals wurde das zerstörte kraftwerk
in eine hülle auch sarkophag genannt aus
rund 7000 tonnen stahl und 400.000
kubikmetern beton verpackt dass dieser
sarkophag nicht ewig halten würde
das war den forschern schon damals klar
und jetzt in den kommenden wochen soll
der reaktor in tschernobyl ein neues 100
meter hohes 160 meter langes und 260
meter breites abschirmen dach bekommen
das new safe kontinent kurz msc soll den
experten noch mal rund 100 jahre zeit
geben um sowohl das die alte hülle als
auch die reaktorblöcke an sich sicher
abbauen zu können sicher ist dabei ein
sehr dehnbarer begriff denn zitat die
herausforderung besteht in der
langfristigkeit sie soll 100 jahre dicht
sein um die zeit für den rückbau zu
haben
die werden wir brauchen da liegt
irgendwo kernmaterial
zusammengeschmolzen den unbekannten
mischung und in irgendwelchen
stockwerken auch wissen wir nicht wo die
brennelemente sind die unsicherheiten
sind enorm so walter traum sprecher des
programms für nukleare entsorgung
sicherheit
und strahlenforschung die situation vor
ort sind also 30 jahre nach dem gau
immer noch chaotisch und auch gefährlich
sicher ist und wird dort noch viele
jahre nichts sein wenn es euch gefallen
hat dass wir auch mal wieder vergangenen
themen neu aufgegriffen haben und mit
euch mit neuen infos dazu versorgen dann
lassen wir gerne genau das einen daumen
nach oben da und wer noch mehr über das
thema wissen will kann sich auch gerne
mal über unseren hörbuch link einen
kostenlosen pro bertrand bei audible
erstellen und dann das hörbuch
tschernobyl gespräche mit lebenden und
toten kostenlos dazu bekommen spannende
gespräche mit zeitzeugen warten also
hier auf euch und nichts verpassen und
darauf liegt nicht verpassen sollte auch
das nächste klick zum video einfach hier
klicken um uns kostenlos zu abonnieren
und wenn ihr irgendwo ihr könnt hier
überall klicken dann kommt er zu einem
video das euch auch ziemlich
interessieren wird nämlich und uns vor
allem aufheitern wird nach diesem video
die top fünf wissenschaftler face also
viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran